[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
إنها ليلة الجمعة في منزل الكعوب
العالية ، حيث يوجد حشد سعيد جيد في العرض الأول لفيلم بانكوك هذا هو benzene [موسيقى] مرحبًا zeppy
[موسيقى
] ومضيفنا الذبحة الصدرية
في المفتي ، إنه مجرد
شخص مشهور  من المعروف أنه يقطع مثل
شفرة الحلاقة على قلب الذهب ،
فالانتقال من عموم إلى بانجينا يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً
والحب والعناية
أساسًا السحب هو فن
التحول ويمكن للجميع القيام بهذا
الفن سواء كنت أنثى أو
متحولة جنسيًا.
ما دمت تشعر بنوع من
التحول داخل الشخصية
أو الماكياج ، أشعر أن هذا هو السحب ، لذلك
دعونا نكون واضحين كيف تصف
نفسك ، سأعتبر نفسي ملكة السحب ،
سأعتبر نفسي كنزًا وطنيًا ،
أنا صغير جدًا
تشتهر تايلاند بما يُعرف باسم
ladyboys وعروض الكاباريه التي
يؤدون فيها
ما يفعله pangina وبيت الكعب
هو فن بقدر ما هو ترفيه
وتعتمد بشكل كبير على
تاريخ البلاد الطويل من الانسيابية بين الجنسين
التغيير
حسنًا ، لا أعرف ما هو شعورك بالنسبة لك في الداخل ، ولكن خارج الأشياء الخارجية بشكل
استثنائي ، شكرًا
لك كيف تشعر
أنني أشعر بالرشاقة ، أشعر بالجمال ،
لكني أشعر بأنني أكثر أنوثة
وأشعر بالشعر الذي يضرب وجهي أشعر
الوهم سأقول كلمة ladyboy لأن هذا
ما
يصفه بقية العالم نعم
أه وليس تحقيرًا على هذا النحو
ولكن يمكن أن يكون
كيف يجب أن تصفه
كيف يمكنك أن تفعل هذا لأن
هناك  لا توجد كلمة تايلاندية ،
ما الذي تستخدمه في قطر الجنس الثالث
أو
مجتمع المثليين ، أعتقد أن هذا هو ما
يشير إليه معظم الناس كاتوي ولكن مع
قطر هناك دلالة في اللغة الإنجليزية
مع
النساء المختلفات يفكرن في ماهية أكاتوري بشكل
مختلف
لأنني  كلمة gutilla التايلاندية عبارة عن مظلة كبيرة
قد يفكر فيها الناس في شخص مثلي الجنس
وأنثوي ،
شخص متحول جنسيًا حتى أنه
يرتدي ملابس متقاطعة ،
لذا
في نهاية اليوم يهتم حقًا
بما تدعونيه  ما دمت تتصل بي
ولكن في تايلاند ، فإنك توافق على أن هناك
انفتاحًا أكبر
بالطبع
من أي مكان آخر في المنطقة بالتأكيد
نعم إذا قلت لك
إنني لم
أرتدي الكعب مطلقًا في حياتي ،
فستخبرني أنني "
أحمق تمامًا حتى لو حاول شخص ما
ارتداء هذه الأشياء الليلة ، فلن
أنكر متعة رؤيتك ترتدي
الكعب ، دعنا نقول فقط إن الحظ السعيد
سأحتاج إلى القليل من التشجيع.
يسارًا ، هذه هي الطريقة التي
تمشي بها عادةً في الحياة ،
أنا معك لن أتخلى عن ذلك أبدًا كيف تفعل
ذلك ، التوازن مخيف ، قم
بتصويب ساقك من فضلك هناك نذهب
نعم
هناك نذهب ، يا
إلهي ، لقد
فهمتها ، أعرف مكارثي  فجأة ، اصطدمت بخطوات
مستقيمة ، أنت مذهل ،
يا إلهي ، لقد تمايلت لقد تراجعت بشكل
أنيق ، لم أكن بالكاد بقيت
مستقيماً ،
ما زلت لا أرغب في القيام بالسحب ، لكن
للحظة ارتديت الكعب بفخر
سأخلعه من أجل  أنت
يا ولم تكسر في
الكاحل لقد احتضنت الضجة  كوك بكل سحره
وشخصيته وقد احتضنني